wenige tage ist das lämmchen alt es ist
gesund schon bald kann es raus auf die
weide zur lammzeit holt sich schaaf wird
kleinhans schon mal unterstützung eines
kollegen rund 700 muttertiere und fast
ebenso viele lämmer müssen versorgt
werden
ded moros um 7 los bis zum 67
was macht man da auch das immer so gut
zu tun hat zu einer hand wärmeabnahme
zeit das ist die ganze nacht nach passt
auf oder füttern der muss erst pusten
müssen klein schneiden sowie die jetzt
raus in die ställe auszumisten
der scharf wird aus mecklenburg
vorpommern hat sich auf die müritz
lämmer spezialisiert sie gelten als
besonders fleisch reich für ein lamm
bekommt der etwa 80 euro
ein muttertier bringt die hälfte doch
die deutschen essen nur wenig lang im
schnitt gerade mal ein kilo pro jahr
mithalten kann da nur wer nicht auf
masse sondern auf qualität setzt jeder
kann sich lange fleisch leisten nicht
jeder mag das lammfleisch viele haben in
alten geschmack von schafen
im inland fleisch denken das hatte aber
ist nicht mehr so lammfleisch ist sehr
hochwertig und hochpreisig doch nicht
jeder ist bereit den preis zu zahlen
fördermittel vom bund und der eu gibt es
kaum noch
die branche kämpft ums überleben wie
auch steht kurz vor dem abgrund die
scharf bestände und auch die zahl der
schafhalter ist in den letzten fünf
jahren um 20 prozent zurückgegangen
sie ist zurückgegangen weil die preise
gestiegen sind die erzeugerpreise
gestiegen sind die kosten sind insgesamt
gestiegen
auch der boden wird immer teurer
schäfer tietz hat schon lange keine
eigenen schafe mehr in der modernen
landwirtschaft sagt er sei für schiffe
einfach kein platz mehr
es wird irgendwelcher mais oder alles
was in der biogasanlage gebraucht wird
wird dort angebaut und das sind die
leute die im moment das sagen haben und
die auch bestimmen ob und für die
schäfer wird immer schlechter
seine leidenschaft für die tiere aber
ist geblieben und seine hilfe auf dem
hof von schaaf wird kleinhans willkommen
ich bin jetzt 58 und ein paar jahren
deutlich hier aus und ich hoffe nach wir
will sondern besondere arbeit nur
deshalb ist hier nennen das
durchschnittsalter der deutschen schäfer
liegt bei 60 jahren
es ist also absehbar wann schlosses mit
einem der ältesten berufe der welt